dude you becoming a god guy would be
crazy
we should just become girl defined and
replace them we should and complete the
meme yes strip all this we're like
secular music is bad
music is a sin we regret everything
we've ever done
and we're here to use our platform to
start new yeah did you hear about that
crazy event this weekend yeah there's
gonna be tons of hot chicks there yeah
that's not our definition of fun sorry
our definition of fun is getting closer
to our creator
and grinder I mean praying yeah
Frank and grinder are pretty close it'll
be funny if people were like have you
seen the girl to find dudes have you
seen them recently and then have you
seen the girl Define girls recently you
know
you know they're hanging out what I said
now right wait what what they're giving
sex ed no because they're married so
it's like cool yeah